so you probably heard that old adage
that every person has at least one good
book in them I believe in something
grander than that I believe that every
great person has at least one great beer
all they need is a fearless brewer like
me to coax it up welcome
so that's odd let's drink it I love the
smell of match in the morning so we are
mashing it in today's an awesome day
here we are doing a batch of a Belgian
white beer with world-class producer and
DJ Z trip he's worked with everyone from
nos to Public Enemy and today he's
working with me I basically sent out a
bat signal and said you sent me your
favorite culinary ingredients we'll kind
of figure out the best ones that go
together we'll layer them in your
discretion and build this beer together
so today it's all about beer remixed DJ
z-trip has headlined festivals like
Coachella and has played for 450,000
people in one sitting when he opened for
the Rolling Stones
named America's best DJ in 2009 he's
done everything from scoring video games
to blowing up the entire remix genre
this is it here's the tasting room nice
thank you for coming coast to clam ass
good morrow Hey I brought my milk crate
you're no stranger to these pop right
yeah man
when you started DJing is this what you
would use that was it started with milk
crates then went to flight cases and now
it's a computer alright so short version
of what we're doing today my friend is
taking one of your favorite styles of
belgian wheat beer but doing basically a
full-on remix of it using your favorite
culinary ingredients great because we
want to brew up a new twist on an
age-old belgian wheat there's curry
powder ginger and chilies oranges and a
ton of different herbs
we're gonna steep these ingredients into
beer to dream up a special recipe kind
of the biggest ingredient by weight
under the water obviously is the sugar
source what would be the equivalent in a
song what's the big what's the base the
foundation of us ah my base would be
beets you know I mean beets is always
sort of every song basically has a tempo
and a beat so what tempo and what beat
what I look be looking for then you
start adding the other ingredients for
me would be melody bass lines you know
top lines trying to figure out sort of
what pairs well with each other also
making sure that things don't clash I
mean there's probably when you know the
list of ingredients that I gave you
you pared down to ones that work well
together do the same thing with me you
can't really mix certain melodies that
aren't in key you know what I mean
because it's off key and it's just sort
of your own you're doing a show and you
know the vibe is it's gonna be like a
more chill show you wouldn't even bother
putting in your crate a bunch of really
intense right right so for the remix
that we're doing I'm taking that back to
the base elements I'll be adding some
fruit this is our a little Randall a
contraption that we came up with on how
we do like real-time spicing we'll get a
sense Randall the enamel animal is a
double chamber filter that you connect
to a beer tap and fill with flavor
enhancing ingredients so that the
alcohol in the beer strips the flavor
from whatever is added and puts it in
the beer next thing you know we're
drinking our breakfast and seeing how
well these things go together wouldn't
be the first time no no
I mean I definitely want to throw ginger
in there but again I don't wanna do too
much of that like it's a definite needs
to be in there yeah I'm probably parsley
over over the base yeah over basil how
are you feeling
are you feeling a little bit every night
I think I literally throw some heat in
there for sure I'm all about that I
chopped up the tumeric you want me to
add tumeric
oh yeah little berry I think a little
bit is good to throw in there yeah we've
got coconut which I'm really kind of
curious to see how that might play off
yeah this why I like the idea of the
coconut with an absolute smorgasbord of
ingredients smashed into Randall it was
time to see just what sort of mashup
z-trip and I had created after running
our base belgian wheat beer through the
chambers for a few minutes we poured our
selves a first taste Cheers actually
doing this do it man Cheers
what do you think of the ingredients we
added which of you kind of stands out
beyond the base I feel like it needs it
needs something a bit more to go for to
the front I'm not getting enough pepper
maybe not enough ginger being that
there's not enough the peppers a great
example where he amplifies heat you know
the way with the scorpions amplified
Chuck date right so with it something
like the peppers you really need the
boil the heat to bring the pepper for it
you can get more of the orange I mean
you can get you get the orange citrusy
care yeah that's definitely happened I
jumped up it's not agree with you that
you you're without the heat component of
doing it in the boil these didn't come
up as much right maybe Ginger's the way
to go yes that's the wing it forward
yeah I like it even triple on the ginger
triplet so high again maybe maybe I like
it and that way it'll be really
different than the wheat beers we brew
before it let's brew this Stewart
working with John one of our in-house
Brewers Z and I crafted a recipe with
some seriously intense portions for this
remix tweak yield and just like making a
mixtape it's time for Z and I to drop
this mad mashup of flavors into our book
we've got a bunch of our slices in here
we bumped up the ginger yeah this
thing's gonna float on top so you know
what you're gonna do I need you to add
the rock adding Rocky's in the next the
rots what I do through the mix right in
there and that's gonna weigh it down so
it doesn't just sit on top of the boil
it'll awesome it'll drop in so the
coconut water is gonna keep everything
nice and loose we got our ginger there
if you want to start I'll add some of
this if you start adding that and the
sound yeah there goes the Chuck D what
would you say who's like a spicy rapper
if you got Chuck D representing ginger
which is like wow maybe rock him or a
big Daddy Kane thinking of a you know
really clever clever rappers that's what
he was known for I'm broken down with
molecules that's like this and it's
spicy and now we're gonna start spinning
what should we spin at home the
Europeans 33 and a third or 45
all right you go ahead hi
I believe we're gonna add that a little
bit earlier and then we're gonna add
this almost raped before flame that's
for one hour boil rough
beer with me alright I'll do it if you
do it whether that's a little bigger we
got to do it we have to do it it's like
a good salsa right here alright it's
green an ornery looking hmm just keeps
going yeah yeah oh it just keeps going
now remember this is intense yeah we
dilute that we're gonna be in business
when z-trip and I first started thinking
about a beer together we don't want to
make just any old beer we wanted to
literally collide beer and music
together so while we've cut C's palate
in this brew now it's time for us to
raise the bar and bring this beer to the
next level I got a buddy tale in Italy a
place called valid and awesome gooey
outside Torino
he's like Renaissance man and then you
look into this fermentation room and you
see these beautiful vats that have
massive headphones on right
Masum like they'll be like a lager that
ferments really slowly and he'll have
Beethoven or something chill you know
right right playing on the help push it
along I hope you put the yeast and a
vibe and so basically you're in the beer
your pals in the beer your favorite
places right but we want to get a little
more Z trip in the got put some beats or
so maybe the sound is again if you're
playing to yeast let me let me put
something together for the yeast I love
it so we routed a just the two of us but
you're saying you want to play a concert
in front of thousands of living
organisms yes looks like it's my my own
Coachella of yeast if you were right
here I love it so this is precious cargo
like coworkers and I rigged up to
carboys filled with Z trips version of a
ream
Belgian white mirror we pinched the
yeast now the plan is to play Z trips
live mix to this carboy full of beer the
vibrations are going to certainly hit
off the yeast we pitched it we pitched
it real good what's right you sit it on
higher dog fish in the sea trip special
brew
thank you
I'm gonna drink beer I miss I'm here to
drop the drink drink beer drink this
drink drink then drink beer just bit I'm
here to drink did you hear that that's
the sounds of tiny little billions of
applauding thanks the part I was great
one question yes most important question
what are we going to name your beer
what finger since I've been rocking to
808 in the trunk right this is the track
that that me and Brill's did for the
yeast
you know banging it giving them some sub
I figured why not name this thing ain't
awaiting the jug love it I love em we
are done yeah well done what's right you
sitting on Cryer dog fish in the sea
trip special brew